exciting announcements straight from
think 2021
including ibm watson orchestrate the
next generation of cloud pack for data
and an expansion to the ibm center for
cloud training
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all
my name is ian and i am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements from ibm cloud
last week ibm held its annual think
event and i'm going to be covering some
of the amazing and groundbreaking
announcements that came from the digital
event
and if we're talking amazing i have to
start with ibm watson orchestrate
orchestry is a new self-serve
interactive ai tool
that will help you reclaim a significant
amount of your work time
to focus on projects that matter watson
orchestrate can help
you perform both mundane and mission
critical tasks faster
talking about everything from preparing
sales proposals to sending emails
scheduling meetings and securing
approvals it's really important to note
that orchestrate isn't just a static bot
programmed by it you initiate work with
the ai tool in a very human way
using common collaboration tools like
slack and email
watson orchestrate is currently in
preview as part of the ibm automation
cloud packs
to learn more about this exciting new
product and the related sessions from
think
check out the blog i've got linked in
the description of this video
the second think announcement i want to
highlight is the next generation of ibm
cloud pack for data
which will help you get started with ai
faster while removing complexity
we've infused new ai power capabilities
into the cloud pack for data that will
become the core components of a new
intelligent data fabric within the
platform this intelligent data fabric
will use
ai to automate complex data management
tasks
and provide dynamic and intelligent data
orchestration
across a distributed landscape the first
set of new capabilities coming to the
cloud pack for data include
auto sql which is a high performance
universal query engine
auto catalog which automates how data is
processed and discovered
and auto privacy which employs ai to
intelligently automate
the identification monitoring and
enforcement of policies on sensitive
data
for the full rundown of new updates and
enhancements to ibm cloud pack for data
check out the link below the final think
announcement i want to cover today
is the expansion of the ibm center for
cloud training
there are a few elements to this
expansion first we've launched ingrid
an augmented reality helper for learners
that is built into the center for cloud
training
second is the introduction of two ibm
cloud specialty learning paths
the first two learning paths are the ibm
cloud for financial services specialty
and ibm cloud satellite specialty best
of all
the introductory modules for both
learning paths are available now at no
charge
finally we're introducing the associate
sre learning path and certification
sre is one of the most demanding and
in-demand i.t technical professions
this learning path will help build the
skills and knowledge required to begin
working in the field
for all the info on the expansion of the
ibm center for cloud training check out
the blog i've got linked below
this has been just a sampling of the
exciting and innovative news to come out
of think 2021
so make sure you check out the on demand
sessions that you can access through the
think site
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you